let's hear from some more people via
Discord at davidpackman.com
Discord we have so many people who want
to chat but we have to pick someone to
talk to and we are next going to be
going to Rick from Southeast Texas Rick
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
Rick sir please unmute
hey David good afternoon thank you sir
sir I do appreciate it my pleasure um
David my uh my question for you today is
I I have trouble with cognitive
dissonance between
you know there's a I don't want to get
into details and I don't want to kick to
you get you kicked off your your radio
Partners but there's certain groups of
people that I watch that are displayed
themselves as Republicans but do very
very good things for society I'll just
say it's relating to to children and
anti-abuse I'll keep it at that
um but what Rick I don't know what
you're talking about
well well so let me let me rephrase
there's a group of people that
um investigate uh tell child Predators
okay and they go after they go after
them online kind of a Chris Hanson style
I'm sure you've heard of them oh these
are the videos I see on Tick Tock where
like someone shows up at a Chick-fil-A
and someone with a camera goes up to
like a 38 year old who's there to meet a
14 year old girl and they confront them
in public or whatever
absolutely yeah I see dangerous to do
certainly I think law enforcement would
say you probably shouldn't do it but
certainly I've seen it done I've seen it
done
yes of course at their at their own risk
but yeah my question is they're they're
doing good clearly so let me say this
they have good intentions right and so
my question is when these kind of people
come out later and say I'm very you know
public and very role-like and you know
how do you best deal with wanting to
support that but also not wanting to
follow along with their baggage so
what's a safe way to do that in your
opinion kind of like listen here's
here's the thing Rick here's the thing
it's not like the Republicans are
Against Child predators and the
Democrats are for them I mean I think
what you're talking about is there's
like a small subset of the vast majority
of the population that's against child
predators that creates a very particular
video based on these stings that are
done uh but that doesn't mean that it's
representative of right-wing views
rather than left wing views right I mean
sort of like saying like hey you know
what I don't know we have such
differences about what the tax rate
should be but I find that Republicans
and Democrats all breathe air as well
well okay but fine but so that's not
really a distinguishing characteristic
so the way I would see it is if you talk
to just about any Republican or just
about any Democrat they're going to tell
you of course I'm against 38 year olds
being predators and finding 12 year old
girls to meet up with I just don't think
that there's anything right-wing about
that perspective
no no and I absolutely agree with that
and that was not necessarily my point
because of course everybody should
should be on the same side in that
regards but my question is when these
people that are clearly doing have good
motives to to do something to even bring
attention to it how do you
um
and then they come out hey I'm trolling
people I'm being a bigot whatever it is
obviously they don't say that but how do
you kind of reconcile that it's a big
dissonance because they kind of talk
about that you don't want to support
that you don't want to give them money
but they're also doing good
well but the police is also working on
getting I just don't know why you would
feel compelled to give money
what are you even giving the money for I
just don't even get it I mean maybe I
just don't understand the whole movement
but I in my mind I would go oh these are
people whose political views I find
completely deplorable and it's a good
thing to get child Predators uh out of
situations where they can be Predators
period I mean I think that's just it I
don't then go how can I donate money but
they hate Jews and what do I I just I
just wouldn't give them any money there
are other ways to deal with
um you know peop people being targeted
by Predators or trafficked or whatever
the case may be you don't have to give
you know some right-wing guy with a with
a cell phone money to do it
I understand okay awesome and thank you
for for that and sorry I wasn't very
clear but no that's okay and uh have a
wonderful day all right you too there is
Rick from Texas with a very powerful
topic for sure why don't we go next to
uh Dylan in Georgia is it do I have this
right it's a series of names Dylan in
Georgia yes welcome Dylan
hey David can you hear me yes I can
oh fantastic this is my first
time oh boy and you're it's your first
time on but your audio is already going
uh completely digital and nuclear
sounds about
all right yeah I mean right now okay all
right Dylan I'm gonna have to let you go
because you sound like a robot on a
cartoon so I'm gonna have to let you go
that's just it's not working
unfortunately and I know the audience
will be very very displeased with me